hi I'm in warden and I have the honor of
being chair of the Friends of the Burke
Library Burke library one of the
libraries of Columbia University and
located here on this campus in case
you're not familiar with it I see a lot
of faces that I haven't seen it other
ones so on that's when I give you all
the information you need in a moment
we'll be hearing from the boss the
director of the Burke library but I just
want to give you a heads up that we do
have copies of the new newsletter if you
didn't get one in the mail that means
you probably are not on our mailing list
and we would love for you to be on the
mailing list because we intend to keep
creating this kind of newsletter and if
we have your email address and/or your
mailing address we can be sure that you
get this information and interestingly
in talking to people here it seems that
many of you did get the information from
either the newsletter or the website
could I see hands as to how many came by
way of the website uh-huh thought so
thank you
we really appreciate it we have one
other one other item that may interest
you
the Burke library is the repository of
some wonderful ancient books and
manuscripts and from them some years
back we started selecting images that
could be on a Christmas card so these
are images from the collection of at the
Burke library and if you're interested
in starting your Christmas cards early
they are for sale there at the table and
we can we can help you with that at the
end of the lecture and now I'd like to
introduce dr. John Weaver the director
of the Burke library
thank you ma'am many of you know not all
of you know how much mm worden has meant
to the Friends of the library over the
past years and we please join me in
expressing our appreciation to her for
all the work that she and the friends
have done for the Brooklyn I just also
want to briefly mention that Seth Caston
is here tonight he's the reference
librarian he's been at the Berk library
for 37 years as a reference librarian
Seth would you please just stand so our
audience can and we celebrate sess
career because he retires this year
after a long and full career and we hope
that he'll continue in his role as a an
assistant an advisor at the Berk library
it's such a delight to have you here as
I went around and met you I realized
there this is a very diverse audience
representing much of the diversity of
New York City and and we had expected
that a topic like this the world
missionary conference you look at the
annuals of modern church history of the
growth of world Christianity and modern
Christianity there is there are a few
moments in the history which are as
significant as the world missionary
conference in 1910 of course this
lecture is a celebration of the hundred
year anniversary of that conference in
Edinboro in 1910 there are a few
locations in the world where the study
of that event can occur in such a
fulsome way as at the Burke library the
Burke libraries you may know holds the
records of the missionary research
library which holds the records of the
world missionary conference and so Brian
and others have come to the Burke
library from around the world to study
this seminal moment in 20th century
Christianity there are a few scholars
who are as qualified I would argue nun
who was where I qualified to speak about
the world missionary conference as Brian
Stanley it's indeed an honor for me to
introduce Brian dr. Stanley is the
professor of world Christianity and the
director of the
Center for the Study of world
Christianity at the University of
Edinburgh previously he worked at the
Henry Martin Center for the Study of
mission and world Christianity at
Cambridge doctor Stanley as he says is a
Cambridge man he did earned his PhD
there in history his dissertation on the
domestic base of the early Victorian
missionary movement I think as the title
suggests he is first and foremost a
historian that has through the course of
his career worked at a variety of
different theological institutions
different denomination ecumenical
certainly in service scope from Baptist
to angle Ken to reform to Methodist
he served in a variety of different
institutions he's taught courses on
world Christianity the theology and
history of World Mission contextual
theologies modern British and American
church history and cumin ism but if you
drill down you see what he really
focuses upon it's on this topic the
world missionary conference Edinburgh in
1910 an ancillary contextual topics the
history of Protestant missions from the
18th to the 20th century modern global
evangelism in the transition in the
early 20th century from race to culture
as a category for describing and
interpreting human difference in 2009
Edmunds published a book by dr. Stanley
entitled the world missionary conference
Edinburgh 1910 I've read the book and
would agree with the words of another
reviewer who recently wrote about the
book that the book is a reliable and
indispensable guide to the original
event another reviewer observed it's a
fascinating study and a good starting
point for reflection on the subsequent
shift in Christianity center of gravity
away from the West not least thanks to
the missionary movement and where it
might go next we look forward to hearing
about that movement
and where it might go next tonight
please join me in welcoming dr. Stanley
a ladies and gentlemen good evening
thank you very much for coming on a cold
night winter seems to have suddenly
arrived in in New York
thank you dr. Weaver and thank you to
the Friends of the Burt library for
their very kind invitation and for the
great honor of delivering the Friends of
the Burt library lecture for 2010 as dr.
Weaver has said the library is a rich
and still to some extent I think
undiscovered treasure trove for
historians of Protestant missions Akuma
is 'm at the growth of world
Christianity certainly I couldn't have
written my book without considerable
time in the library where if I had it
would have been a very much poorer book
so I'm enormous ly indebted to the
seminary and to the library for the
hospitality they provided and so this is
one way of saying thank you to to the
Burke library for the enormous
contribution it made to the book and the
very I don't think she's he's here I
would like to thank especially Ruth
Tonka's Cameron the archivist who's been
unfailingly helpful throughout my
research and all of her staff and Stefan
in particular they've always been a
great a great source of support so thank
you well 100 years on how should we
remember the world missionary conference
should we venerate it as for formal
beginning of the institutional
ecumenical movement as the first step
along the road that led to the formation
of the Church of South India in 1947 one
year later in Amsterdam - the opening
Assembly of the World Council of
Churches well the origins are both the
Church of South India and the WCC as is
well known Oh a great deal - the impetus
supplied by the Edinburgh conference but
we need to remember that Protestant
Okuma nism in a missionary context had
already taken institutional shape
certainly in North America and in much
of Europe well before 1910 while in both
China and India indigenous Christian
leaders and missionaries were already
engaged in serious discussions about
structured forms of missionary
cooperation in China a committee to
discuss Protestant church union was
formed as early as November 1902 the
shanghai centenary missionary conference
of 1907 though not yet ready to go to
commit itself to the goal of a united
church recommended the formation of the
federal union of all protestant churches
in china so we didn't all suddenly begin
at Edinburgh in 1910 nevertheless v the
misconception that Edinburgh 1910
somehow marked the genesis of the akima
the ecumenical movement rather than a
major milestone in it has survived
tenaciously here and there even for out
this year centennial commemorations
equally I think it also remains knit
necessary to reiterate the rather
obvious point
but the Edinburgh assembly was a
conference of Missionary Society
delegates convened to talk about
missionary problems it was not a
conference of delegates of churches
convened to discuss church unity for
problem for many of us I suspect is that
the more we focus on Edinburgh 1910 as
what it was a missionary event the more
embarrassed we become for it was
overwhelmingly white and Protestant in
its delegate composition entirely
unashamed in its acceptance of Western
colonialism and unambiguously committed
to the now unfashionable view that
Christianity was destined by divine Fiat
to the eventual conquest of all other
world faiths what I intend to do this
evening is to analyze an aspect of the
conference but I hope may yield some
fruitful insights for reflection on
Christian witness in today's very
different world namely how perceptive
and how accurate was the conference in
its reading of the signs of the times
and hence in its deduction of
appropriate priorities for the world
mission of the church they want to begin
not with the conference itself but with
in an address given in Edinburgh nine
months later by the Scottish theologian
professor David Ayer scamp's now Cairns
had played a crucial role in the
conference he was chairman of one of its
study Commission's commission for which
studied the missionary message in
relation to non-christian religions and
the deeply reflective report of that
commission has been more extensively
studied by modern scholars than have any
of the Edinburgh 1910 documents because
of its obvious interest to those
concerned with interfaith issues today
so Cannes was the chairman of that
report in March 1911 on the 23rd of
March he was back in Edinburgh
addressing a conference of Scottish
students under the auspices of the
student Christian movement that was the
British arm of the International
Protestant student movement that was so
closely linked to the Edinburgh
conference the advertised subject of
Cairns address on the 23rd of March 1911
was the vocation of Scotland in view of
her religious heritage but Cannes
devoted the substantial opening portion
of his address to an analysis of the
condition of the world which might
equally well have come from the lips or
the pen of John our mart-mart of course
the American Methodists lay Evangelist
who chaired the world missionary
conference and who chaired Commission
one on carrying the gospel to all the
non-christian world and the central
preoccupations of Cairns remarks in this
opening section of his address to the
Edinburgh students are almost identical
to those which you will find in moths
commissioned one report submitted to the
Edinburgh conference the year before
Cairns would undoubtedly have read mops
report and evidently endorsed its
principal arguments where we don't need
to posit Mont as the sole or even for
primary influence on Cairns address now
light mots Commission one report cans in
his address rapidly honed in on what was
then known as the Orient what he termed
the dark continent of Africa I'm sorry
there's a lot of politically incorrect
terminology evening what he termed the
dark continent of Africa and the advance
of Islam were mentioned on the first
page but only to be
merrily dismissed in favor of India and
above all of the farthest East for it is
here that the interest is sharpest cans
observed that a strange tremor of unrest
has suddenly spread across Asia from
Bombay to Mukden Western India and
Manchuria being two of the principal
fields of Scottish Presbyterian
missionary endeavor these tremors were
produced he said by the jarring
encounter of two mighty tectonic forces
on the one hand the ancient religions
and civilizations of Asia and on the
other the incursion of new cultural
influences from the West one of these
was Christianity but Cannes was in
little doubt that the more potent
disruptive influence was of a rather
different kind he said wherever the new
scientific knowledge comes throughout
the Orient there the ancestral faiths
must wither and die those Eastern
nations cannot assimilate the techniques
of Western civilization and Western
militarism without assimilating the
scientific method on which fees are
based and where the scientific method
comes the old faiths must sooner or
later go
the real alternative that lies before
China and Japan if they persist on their
present paths must be between
Christianity and secularism the alarming
prospect that Cannes was raising in the
minds of his student audience was that
East Asia would go over on masse to
atheism an outcome whose disastrous
reaction he said would be felt for our
Christendom for growing a religion which
British Christians lamented to find in
their own society was as nothing in
comparison will with what would soon be
observable if this great spiritual
disaster comes to pass if Christendom
idly allows it to
kans believed that a certain instinct
and divination of this portentous trend
impelled the international student
movement of which this meeting was a
part and he noted the same conviction
certainly lay behind the world
missionary conference in this city of
Edinburgh last June same conviction
about the need to rescue East Asia from
atheism the vocation of Scotland in
particular and more broadly the calling
of the Western Protestant churches as a
whole was nothing less than to halt and
even reverse the downward slide of Asia
and East Asia in particular towards a
godless future that would prove deeply
damaging to the global fortunes of
Christianity Scotland with its great
missionary tradition and its Reformed
Theological emphasis on the absolute
sovereignty of God over all areas of
human activity not excepting the
turbulent waters of politics and
ideology was according to Cairns
uniquely well placed to discharge the
task
kans message was distinctively shaped
for a Scottish theological audience but
the essential priorities which he
identified for global missionary
strategy were a faithful replication of
the central thrust of mops message to
the Edinburgh conference as expressed
especially in the Commission one report
three unifying premises may be
identified underlying both Cannes
address and mops report now I want to
examine these three assumptions in some
detail and make some reference to how
the subsequent course of world Christian
history has either borne out or
invalidated filles assumptions first of
all the religious impact of
modernization the first premise evident
in both Cannes is addressed and the
Commission one report
was the assumption that the ancient
religions of Asia were losing their hold
on the educated elites who were being
drawn to a modern and progressive
ideologies emanating from the West's
modernization of education and economy
it was assumed would inevitably lead to
the disintegration of patient's
traditional faiths this erosion of the
religious foundations of Asian
civilizations and the uniquely plastic
condition has mocked positive Asian
nations constituted both opportunity and
threat for Christianity in China as also
in Korea Japan India Turkey and Persia
the question was whether the church
would be able to channel the
strengthening currents of political
educational and religious reform in the
direction of Christianity if the tide is
not set towards Christianity during the
next decade both in the far east and the
near East
it may be turned against us in the
decade following report noted how the
ancient Confucian society of China was
turning from its conservative
preoccupation with the traditions of the
ancestors to a focus on the future this
was a trend that had impressed itself on
John Motte during his furred visit to
China in 1907 when he had been struck by
the hung hunger of China's student class
to seize new educational opportunities
abroad especially in Tokyo the
Commission one report observed that
thousands of ambitious Chinese use were
going to study in Japan America and
Europe to prepare themselves for the
leadership of the new China their
appetite for Western education and
scientific knowledge was not argued an
invitation for missions to present the
latest scientific truth along with the
gospel thus showing the Chinese that all
truth is one and leading them to accept
the gospel
sugared via coating of Western scientism
the priority was therefore to expand
greatly the Christian educational
enterprise in China following a policy
that may be denominated as Christianity
plus it is Western education that the
Chinese are clamoring for and will have
if we can give it to them plus
Christianity they will take it if we
cannot give it to them they will get it
elsewhere without Christianity and that
speedily now such widening exposure to
Western learning did not however imply
that China's long-standing tradition of
anti foreign ism was about to evaporate
on the contrary mark discern did the new
national spirit coursing through China's
educated classes a redoubled insistence
on China for the Chinese and a
strengthening hostility to many aspects
of foreign influence the recognition
that ought to have led more to question
the assumption that education offered by
the missions would inevitably lead to
the acceptance of Christianity as part
of the package China his report
concluded presented the spectacle of a
great Empire in a state of flux a mass
of plastic ideological metal lying inert
in the furnace of revolutionary change
ready to be set in either a Christian or
a materialist mold the outcome would
depend on what proper plant and force
were it had in other words on whether
Christian missions were willing to
devote sufficient personnel and
resources to the furnace of a China in
the midst of revolutionary change the
diagnosis offered by the report proved
to be extraordinarily accurate it was
not inconceivable in 1910 but the
currents of modernizing reform and
nationalist politics in various parts of
Asia would flow over the next two to
three decades in directions broadly
simple
to Christianity in India until Gandhi's
very public attack in 1936 to seven on
Christian proselytism as a threat to
Indian national identity and Hindu
tolerance it was not wholly clear that
the nationalist movement would take a
strongly Hindu form synthesizing India's
ancestral faith with modern political
ideologies in a way that neither moth
nor Cairns had contemplated the
so-called mass or people movements of
Dalits Untouchables as they were then
called into Christianity maintained
extraordinary momentum in the two
decades after 1910 increasing the
Christian population of India by an
estimated 40 percent between the 1911
and 1931 sentences far in excess of the
rate of growth of the national
population however in the wake of
Gandhi's campaign against conversion the
rate of Christian expansion in India
slowed the famous declaration in 1935 of
BR Ambedkar spokesman for the
untouchables that though born a Hindu he
would not die a Hindu did not in fact
raise widespread hopes that he might
choose Christianity and boetker of
course followed by hundreds of thousands
of his followers finally converted to
Buddhism exactly 21 years later on the
14th of October 1956 in China on the
other hand Christiane hopes remained
buoyant for longer Republican China
under sun yat-sen adopted a broadly
pro-christian stance and through the
influence of the YMCA the new Western
educated elite gravitated for a time
towards Christianity by 1922 the YMCA
could claim 24,000 student members the
further 54 thousand members of city
associations throughout China Sun
yat-sen successor Chiang kai-shek
married a devout Methodists
mei-ling in 1927 was baptized in October
1930 and became a regular Bible reader
and man of Prayer after his traumatic
imprisonment by to rebel warlords at sea
on in December 1936 it was not wholly
foolish of missionary observers to
imagine that he was China's greatest
hope at the present time nevertheless by
1927 - eight - the anti-christian
movements in China had confronted
Christian missions with the
uncomfortable fact that their promise of
national South strengthening and
modernization through the medium of
Christianity had been upstaged by an
ideology of exactly the atheist fear
variety of which Mott and Cairns had
warned Marxist Leninist despite being
more Western both in its origins and in
its philosophical texts German was
Christianity appeared to offer the
Chinese elite the same material benefits
as did the Christianity plus packaged
marketed by the missions but without the
need to accept foreign tutelage and
informal control Protestant missions in
Republican China continued to invest
heavily in higher education and to
present Christianity as a foundation of
scientific progress at Shandong
Christian University in Jinan the white
Wright Institute in Museum founded by
the English Baptist missionary Jess
white right in 1887 displayed four
wonders of Western science Robert Speer
hailed as the most effective piece of
University Extension work which can be
found in Asia if not in the world
however the methodology of Christianity
plus was fundamentally flawed China
provides the most telling example of how
mots analysis was both uncannily
prescient but at the same time
dangerously unaware of the ultimate
implications of the strategic emphases
which he was urging Western mission
to adopt the second premise underlying
the missionary strategy outlined in the
Commission report and in Kansa address
was that missionary efforts should be
concentrated on those portions of
humanity that were deemed to have the
greatest collective vitality and hence
maximal potential to influence others
either towards the acceptance of
Christianity or its rejection and here
the influence of contemporary racial
Theory changed as it was with social
Darwinists connotations was implicit and
occasionally made explicit but Chinese
observe the report were the opposite of
certain decaying races with which
missions also have to do their energy
and endurance made them hard to win
certainly but decidedly worth winning a
similar verdict was applied to the
Japanese whose advanced state of mental
moral and material civilization was said
to make them the natural leaders of the
Orient Japan was already the dominant
power in the Korean Peninsula within two
months of the conclusion of the
Edinburgh conference on the 22nd of
August 1910 Japan would annex Korea
there's a formal colony the
evangelization of Japan was vast and
urgent imperative not simply for the
sake of its own inhabitants but also
because this ascendant Asian colonial
power in its growing rationalism and
materialism posed the potential threat
to walk the report described as the
childlike faith of career and
Protestants Koreans were characterized
as a childlike race who's ready
acceptance of Christianity was a cause
for celebration but also potential
anxiety that they might prove equally
ready to accept a rationalistic creed
from their dominant neighbor
there's for the races which were branded
as not merely childlike but decaying and
I'm afraid Africans were in mind here
they too needed the gospel urgently but
for precisely the opposite reason to
that which impelled evangelism in China
or Japan African traditional systems of
belief labeled by the report as animism
or fetishism were it was confidently
predicted destined to succumb within a
generation to the first higher
monotheistic religion with which they
came into contact in the light of a
threatening advance of Islam into
Equatorial Africa
the only question therefore was whether
the Dark Continent shall become
Mohammedan or Christian African religion
it was said had no future paganism is
doomed in introducing its section on
Africa the report made in passing were
telling common that India and China were
the two great mission fields of the
world and proceeded as if in
justification of his statement to note
the sparse nature of Africa's population
which was computed to be less than 15
persons per square mile
in comparison to China's ratio of over
260 to the square mile now Mart
expressed confidence but under he said
more settled and propitious conditions
in the future the meager population of
Africa would increase enormously
nevertheless he was pessimistic about
the survival of what he called African
primitivism which he saw as constituting
peculiarly fertile soil for conversion
there are but a few primitive races or
peoples left in the world and the
opportunity afforded the Christian
Church to reach them under most
favorable conditions can last but a
brief season Africa of us had insistent
claims of its own to make on the
allocation of Western
missionary resources and even the
occasional missionary voice from Asia
was prepared to recognize this de hast
the British director of the China Inland
Mission merged in his questionnaire
reply which we have upstairs that the
situation in Africa constitutes perhaps
the most urgent call upon the Christian
Church at the present time the record of
existing well-organized work in Africa
hast believed indicated that it would
probably be comparatively easy to win
the rest the Commission one report
concluded that the African continent
offered the prospects and indeed the
necessity of an imminent battle with the
Islam for the soul of traditional
religionists and even of rapid and
widespread tribes of the gospel however
not appeared to believe that the
strategic significance of Africa for the
global future of Christianity was
limited this may have been because he
was ambivalent about the likely future
trajectory of Islam although the
Commission one report warned delegates
of the aggressive nature of Muslim
expansion in Africa Malaya Sumatra and
of the resurgence of Indian Islam
particularly amongst low caste groups
paradoxically it also informed them but
globally Islam was making no marked
intellectual or spiritual progress the
religion they were assured was
disintegrating philosophically into
competing sects and parties lacking in
creative energy and struggling to retain
the allegiance of Muslims who were
attracted to the modern learning here
March reflected the optimistic views
expressed by the leading American
advocate of missions to the Muslim world
Samuel dreamer sway myrrh had written in
1907 that Islam as a religion was doomed
to fade away in time
for the advance of humanity civilization
and enlightenment you see if Islam had
no long-term future the significance of
the short-term religious context contest
in Africa however urgent and fiercely
contested it might be was relativized
one wonders how more towards Weimar
would have reacted to the statistics
published earlier this year a remarkable
book the Atlas of global Christianity
published by Edinburgh University Press
which estimate that over the century
since 1910 the average annual rate of
growth of Islam worldwide has been 1.9
7% compared with 1.3 3% for Christianity
so much for imminent disintegration they
might have been rather less surprised
and more gratified to learn that in
Africa on the other hand the rate of
Christian growth over the century three
point a two percent the surpassed the
rate of Muslim growth two point three
eight with an ease that confounds for
more pessimistic predictions made in
1910 but Africa stood on the brink of
becoming a Muslim continent
what Mott along with almost all of the
delegates at Edinburgh in 1910 would
have struggled to understand is that
traditional African approaches to the
spirit world were not so comprehensively
doomed in the face of encroaching modern
enlightenment as they anticipated but
rather have been incorporated and
substantially reeked rafted within a
Christian framework it's not easy for
our generation that has come to make an
almost automatic mental association
between Africa and the missionary to
appreciate that only a century ago the
continent of Africa was still of
distinctly secondary importance to India
the jewel in the imperial crown in the
minds of British missionary thinkers and
of even more
marginal significance to most American
Protestant missionary strategist whose
attentions like those of their
compatriots who harbored imperialist
aspirations were firmly fixed on the
Pacific Rim the statistical atlas of
Christian missions prepared for the
Edinburgh conference by Commission won a
great expense as a companion to a report
revealed that there were more North
American foreign missionaries working in
Japan than in the whole of the African
continent 769 to 734 in East South East
and South Asia as a whole there were
nearly seven times as many American
North American Protestant missionaries
as there were in Africa in Britain the
disproportion between Asia and Africa
was less marked though still significant
the atlas suggested see what about for a
half thousand British missionaries were
working in East South East and South
Asia as compared with 2,200 Africa after
the first world war these ratios would
begin to reverse as for political
conditions for missionary work in parts
of Asia notably China deteriorated in
the force of ascendant nationalist
movements while conversely missionary
opportunities in Africa steadily
expanded under the umbrella of colonial
protection and educational subsidies the
number of Protestant missionary
personnel serving in Asia decreased
markedly from sixteen thousand six
hundred and sixty-three in 1925 to
fourteen thousand 318 in 1938 whereas
those serving in Africa showed a
significant increase after the Second
World War the transposition of Western
missionary priorities became more marked
as the doors closed to Western missions
first in China and then in march of the
indian sub-continent the corresponding
reorientation to tropical Africa
most marked in the case of American
conservative evangelical or
fundamentalist missions although
Catholic missions also contributed to
the geographical shift by 2010 according
to the atlas of global Christianity the
number of North American missionaries
this time including Catholics working in
Africa had reached 53 thousand one
hundred nearly ten times as many as
those working in Asia and even eclipsing
the substantial American missionary
presence in Latin America in terms of
North American missionary numbers the
atlas suggests that Asia now ranks below
even Oceania while missionaries from
Europe working in Africa also outnumber
those working in Asia it's interesting
to note that European missions are now
numerically a more significant presence
in Asia than American ones a total
reversal of what had been the disturb
you
distribution and I think it's
particularly sobering to observe that
this striking geographical recon
centrale of Western missionary forces
over the last century has followed
rather than initiated trends in the
growth of world Christianity whether by
political necessity or strategic choice
or a combination of the two
Western missions over the last century
have refocused their attention on the
continent where Christianity has taken
independent route most easily and have
largely abandoned the goal that was
uppermost in the minds of strategists in
1910 the endeavor to capture four
political and religious elites of Asia
for Christ before they succumbed to the
rival attractions of Western materialist
ideologies for European Protestants from
the era of ziegenbock
onwards the beginning of the 18th
century the river of Christian mission
had flowed primarily from west to east
this was because the first Protestant
missions to establish themselves as
imperial powers Denmark the Netherlands
Britain turned their attention
increasingly to Asia and away from their
initial preoccupation with the Caribbean
and the Americas and British and
European and Protestant missionary
priorities increasingly followed suit
especially after the achievement of
slave emancipation in the British Empire
in 1833 - for which was followed with
almost indecent haste by by the
withdrawal of most British missionary
societies from the Caribbean American
Protestants made this oriental
preoccupation their own but with a
distinctive geographical emphasis on
both the eastern rim of Asia and the
western rim of Asia not so much on the
Indian subcontinent that absorbed so
much British missionary energy Americans
of course also devoted substantial
missionary resources to their southern
continental neighbor Latin America the
decision to exclude from the Edinburgh
conference agenda all missions aimed at
historic Catholic Orthodox or oriental
Christian populations decision taken in
April 1909 in deference to the scruples
of anglo-catholics was a bitter pill for
American evangelicals to swallow a large
portion of their mission field was
deleted from the agenda the forcible
severance
in 1910 of Latin America from other
fields of Protestant missionary activity
had the effect of reinforcing still more
strongly the unspoken equations in the
minds certainly of European Protestants
between Christian and Western
non-christian and Eastern only gradually
in the course of a 20th century as the
balance of mission resources shifted
from Asia to Africa
and as latin-american missions elbowed
their way back onto the ecumenical
Protestant agenda after the 1916 panama
congress on christian work in latin
america only then did the old
orientalists juxtapositions of religious
geography begin to fade to be supplanted
initially by a new vertical idea along
ideological juxtaposition between
christian north and non-christian south
but this in its turn gradually inverted
itself from the 1970s onwards into a
third and diametrically opposite
antithesis which has now become a truism
of religious studies discourse namely
the opposition between post-christian
north and new christian self third
assumption indigenous agency and
appropriation the third premise
discernible both in Cairns is address
and in John marks report was the tacit
assumption that Christians from the
non-western world had only a subsidiary
though perhaps important part to play in
shaping the future of world Christianity
now there were speakers at Edinburgh who
articulated a bold if loosely defined
vision of what the face the future world
Christianity might look like it would
not they said be a monochrome
replication of Western styles but a
truly Catholic and universal family
which would incorporate for example
distinctively Chinese or Japanese or
Indian expressions of Christian truth
and worship most notable in this respect
was the anglo-catholic Anglican
Archbishop of Birmingham Charles Gore
chairman of Commission three on
Christian education whose report
insisted that the final estate illogical
vision held out by the New Testament in
Revelation chapter 21 was a vision of
all nations bringing the gear
of their distinctive racial
characteristics into the inclusive
community of the City of God but the
efforts made at edinburgh by folk like
gore to articulate a theology of
legitimate plurality within the
catholicity of the global household of
God were patchy and were founded on
dubious notions of racial essentialism
they were rarely if ever extended to
those races deemed to be primitive they
featured only minimally in moths
activists program of winning the world
through a program of evangelization led
by Western missionary agencies both
cairns and mark conceived of global
evangelization as a movement which
ultimately depended on the standards of
christian spirituality and zeal set
within europe and north america indeed
the implicit but touchingly bold claim
of Kansa address in 1911 was was that it
was the we nation of scotland with its
particular inheritance of reformed
theology democratic education and
missionary enthusiasm whom God was
calling to play a pivotal role in the
divine strategy for the salvation of
asia's countless millions to be fair the
Commission one report did as for
quotation on the slide makes clear pay
homage to the necessary role of Asian
and African Christians in the task of
evangelization he called in particular
for the more effective training of
catechists evangelists and Bible women
figures who would be of central
importance in the growth of popular
Christianity in Asia and Africa over the
next century however the very next
paragraph of a report went on to assert
quote that a crucial factor in the
evangelization of a non-christian world
is the state of the church in Christian
lands
the missionary movement would only
become irresistible and triumphant was
the phrase if there was a higher level
of spiritual consecration among members
of what the report term for home church
the opening chapter of the report had
also revealed its presuppositions by
drawing a comparison between the
expansion of African Islam which was
essentially the work of indigenous
agents and Christianity where it was
said until a force of native workers can
be prepared Christianity must be spread
by Europeans who differ greatly from the
natives now although the comparison was
not without foundation even as early as
1910 this statement represented a
serious undervaluation of the place that
indigenous Christians already occupied
in the process of evangelization in
fields such as Uganda or Yorubaland the
largest British mission agency the
Church Missionary Society had in 1906
nearly 10 times as many accredited
native agents 8850 as it had European
missionaries 975 even observers of
global religious trends in 1910 2:11 as
perceptive as mortal Cairns undoubtedly
were made no essential distinction
between the future of the Western
missionary movement and the future of
world Christianity for the latter they
assumed would be fundamentally dependent
on and coextensive with performer one
hundred years later it is patently
obvious to us that these two global
religious processes have proved to be
though not entirely unrelated clearly
separable and often markedly divergent
we are well aware that the players who
scarcely made it onto the cast list
at the world missionary conference in
1910 have proved to be among the key
actors in the subsequent transformation
of Christianity into a religion that is
rooted increasingly in the cultural soil
of the southern hemisphere African
American missionaries Pentecostals
prophets prophetesses and African
initiated churches feature hardly at all
in veep Edinburgh reports there were at
least six perhaps eight or even more
African American delegates present at
Edinburgh
they even convened a separate caucus
meeting for all colored delegates during
the conference which was advertised in
the conference daily paper but we do not
know who turned up to the meeting the
Commission reports however give
relatively little attention to the role
of African American missions in the
evangelization of West Africa for
example Pentecostals were becoming
increasingly visible on the Christian
stage by 1910 but since their growing
presence as individuals scattered in
different locations throughout the world
was not yet formalized
into separate Pentecostal missionary
agencies they did not qualify for
representation at Edinburgh
Nazz for the first African initiated
churches the only mention they receive
in mots report was of a sweepingly
dismissive kind the Ethiopian churches
of South Africa are described as a
mischief spreading through the country a
superficial and largely emotional form
of Christianity unable to resist the
disintegrating and corrupting influences
of surrounding heathenism nevertheless
the report did include a section
specifically devoted to organized
evangelistic work on the part of the
native churches it took due note of such
non-western missionary initiatives as
the West African missions of Jamaican
Presbyterians and Anglicans V s as are
ours
national missionary society of
India and the Indian missionary society
of tuna Valley or the Telugu Baptist
natal mission whose first overseas
missionary to the indentured sugarcane
workers on the plantations of Natal John
Raya was a delegate at Edinburgh of the
American Baptist foreign missionary
society an Indian sent as a missionary
to Africa by an Indian missionary agency
a hundred years ago or the report also
noted the earliest ventures by Korean
Protestants to spread the gospel among
the Korean diaspora in locations such as
Jeju quail part Island Siberia Manchuria
and even Hawaii and California missions
from what would now be turned the global
south with us already in evidence by
1910 and were warmly welcomed by Mart
even if he could not refrain from adding
as a concluding comment but in most of
the cases referred to above it should be
noted that the counsel and guidance of
the European missionaries have been
fraternally asked and fraternity given
contrary to what is often alleged
Edinborough 1910 did not confine its
definition of missions to Western
endeavours but it did assume that
Western leadership of the whole
enterprise was both appropriate and
destined to remain intact for the
foreseeable future what can we say in
conclusion well both David Cairns and
John met John Mark Twain of intelligence
insight perhaps exceptional breath for
vision in varying measure these
qualities were shared by other leaders
and delegates of the world missionary
conference in their perception that the
leading nations of Asia were in
unusually plastic condition peculiar me
noble at this pivotal point in their
history to being molded by powerful
ideologies from their
various quarters they were not far wrong
but at the same time their field of
vision had the number of serious blind
spots in the long term Christianity
would suffer more than it gained from
the attempts of missions to yoke it's
message to Western scientific values and
progress they underestimated the
capacity of the ancient faiths of Asia
to retain their hold even on modern
urban and educated people they also
seriously misjudged the capacity of us
in Islam to survive and even flourish
within a modern environment they had
very little sense of how far the future
of world Christianity was to be shaped
by African and other indigenous peoples
whom they labeled as decaying primitive
and devoid of the requisite cultural
resources to articulate their own
distinctive incarnations of the
Christian gospel so they had their blind
spots nevertheless I have a suspicion
that if the Proceedings of the various
Centennial missionary conferences would
have been held this year in Edinburgh in
Tokyo Cape Town and then over the last
few days at the Boston Theological
Institute if the proceedings of those
mission conferences were to be subjected
in 100 years time to critical dissection
by scholars in the light of the course
that world Christianity has actually
taken in the 21st century I suspect that
the diagnosis and policy prescriptions
advanced in these conferences of our own
generation will prove to be no less
flawed no less partial in perception no
less ideologically conditioned than
those of our predecessors a century ago
ultimately our responses to the
pronouncements made in 1910 will depend
our own theological and philosophical
commitments for all of our Western
cultural by
seize the delegates at Edinboro 1910
shared a common conviction that the
gospel of Christ was good news for all
human beings without exception and
therefore was not to be confined within
the frontiers of European or American
Christendom this theological absolutism
if we want to call it that so
uncongenial too many pallets today was
in fact the foundation for the
construction of Christianity as what it
is today a multicultural world religion
thank you very much
we have time for just a couple of
questions if you're harboring any we
would ask if you have a question that
you state it pretty loudly because we
don't have any mics here for you so you
might want to repeat any that aren't
heard well so that we're on the
electronic media I was a lot to take in
wasn't it
years do pick up cervical drills think V
yeah the question is what Mahdavi
outstanding trends would emerge from the
conferences held this year marking the
centenary I think the biggest contrast
to 1910 or one of the biggest contrast
is in 1910 they didn't talk about
theology everybody assumed they knew
what Christianity was the only question
was how you how you should propagate it
and questions of faith and order were
deliberately kept off the agenda in 1910
that was the way in which they hope they
would keep everybody on board but it
also reflected this sort of undisturbed
consensus within the Protestant world a
broadly evangelical world we all know
what Christianity is it's simply a case
of how to target the message most
effectively in contrast in 2010 most of
the time is actually spent arguing about
what Christian mission means in a
pluralist world well it was pluralist in
1910 but we're much more aware of it now
perhaps pluralism is now on our doorstep
it's not over there and that's a big
difference so a lot of time is has been
spent on trying to rescue some sense of
what what is integral and central to
Christian mission without doing any
injustice to religious integrity of
those of other faiths and you can
imagine that you know not everybody
agrees in the way in which that
conundrum is is approached that's the
probably the biggest difference so many
others as well I mean looking back a
hundred years and having been involved
in organizing a much smaller event in
Edinburgh this time with only 300 rather
than the 1200 they had 1200 plus
19:10 I must say I have enormous
admiration for JH Oldham who organized
the nineteen can conference without
email without jet travel and it went
like clockwork whereas we had email we
had jet travel and well I won't tell you
about
within a second
since night
why
never very considerable presence in East
Asia
I've been comparative too you know the
size of a Japanese population very large
missionary present in Japan a very large
missionary presence in China a rapidly
growing American missionary presence in
Korea so in fact there's a very close
correlation between American strategic
concerns with East Asia American
economic interests in East Asia because
great deal of American trade is is
focused on East Asia at this time and
the rapidly growing proportion and and
the missionary concerns what they what
they're neglecting is Africa relatively
few American missions involved in Africa
compared with post Second World War
where Africa the in American investment
in Africa is enormous in Christian terms
mission
well a lot of issues around we can't
begin I think to unpack the law in terms
of a relationship of a missionary
movement to colonialism there there are
two sides to the coin yes on the face of
it you look at the Edinburgh reports and
the questionnaire responses and they are
saturated in the language and
perspectives of colonialism and yet
there is some very forthright indignant
criticism of the British Empire though
by both British and American
missionaries particularly in areas of
Islamic predominance because of British
Empire worked by indirect rule it worked
through Muslim agents and in practice
that meant the British Empire did more
to spread Islam and it did spread
Christianity in areas like Sudan and
northern Nigeria so they're deeply
unhappy about that they're deeply
unhappy about moral issues the red
rubber atrocities in the Congo and so on
Christian Christian thinking accepted
the basic principle of Empire that so
did socialists thinking by the way at
the time it was very critical of the
conduct the the wider issue of you know
how we construct a theology of focused
on the missio day and one that takes
proper concern of the integrity and
dignity of the other and yet still I
would want to say asserts that Christ's
love and the good news of Christ's
message still extends to that other that
is is what that's what all these
conferences have been wrestling with and
that that's where you know there is
enormous work still to be done
sorry that's hardly beginning to touch
on on big issues thank you for the
question
one last well you have to understand
British ecclesiastical politics I think
it's all to do with Anglican politics
and Oldham is desperately concerned he
must have the Church of England in its
full breath on board if this is to be a
really significant and powerful
confluence of conference that will
attract general support and respect and
therefore it cannot just have the
evangelicals as previous missionary
conferences had done they've been
previous missionary conferences
including one in New York in 1900 yeah
but only evangelicals came the
anglo-catholics didn't come the key
thing about Edinburgh is the Anglo
Catholics are on board the full range of
the Church of England and so they
effectively a hold a gun to Aldens head
and they say if you include in the
statistics and it was actually focused
on the statistics if you include in the
statistics work done by American
Protestant missions in Latin America or
among Orthodox or oriental Christian
populations we would withdraw and holder
was so anxious that he made a special
trip to New York to try and sort it out
well that's it for tonight but we'll be
here again with another interesting
lecture and I hope that see you all then
February 17th is the date and it has to
do with a new translation or commentary
look forward to seeing you then good
night and please do join us become a
member of the Friends of the library
will appreciate it